man has been studying space around our
earth
for the past several thousand years in
this comparatively short period by
astronomical standards
we have managed to discover a great many
riddles lurking in the cosmos
most of them can be theoretically
described to this or that degree
however others defy our understanding
completely
one of these mysterious things lurking
in space
is the dark flow which may rightfully be
called one of the most
amazing mysteries of the universe
cosmo the first in outer space
the world around us is full of things
we're not quite able to explain today
but it is these mysteries that give
people inspiration to create worlds
where a fantasy becomes a reality
one of these worlds can be enjoyed in
the game rage shadow legends where you
can join
any of the 13 factions personally i am
quite fascinated by the high elves
their support is said to have helped the
forces of good stand against the forces
of evil for thousands of years
now here is one of my favorite champions
lisandra
with her amazing skills like
transference exhaustion and
energize you can come off victorious in
a fight with many enemies you may
encounter in the game
also raid shadow legends regularly
releases a bunch of great seasonal
updates
one of them is the doom tower a giant
challenge where you will have to face 12
bosses
and also make it through the secret
rooms full of amazing goodies
to immerse into all this ambiance you
simply have to download this free game
from the link below for ios
android or pc this will give you a free
spirit champion as well as 50
000 silver five mystery shards and a lot
more bonuses
hurry up as this present is only valid
for a month
you can find it in the inbox in the top
right hand corner
the dark flow is a term referring to a
probable coordinated motion of galaxy
clusters
it was identified back in 2008 when the
cosmic microwave background radiation
was
being studied this phenomenon is often
easy to confuse with the motion caused
by the great attractor
the dark flow on the other hand is a
unique process
whose nature is quite baffling and
elusive
according to the standard cosmological
model of the universe
the motion of galaxy clusters is
supposed to be random and chaotic
this is deduced from the fact that all
objects in space are located in their
unique places
and none of them have masses completely
identical to others
however not so long ago a collected
motion of at least
1400 clusters was discovered in the
universe
and the reason for this anomaly is still
not identified
the discovery was made thanks to the
analysis of data collected by the
wilkinson microwave anisotropy probe
or the wmap whose mission was to study
the cmb radiation
the discovery was made possible thanks
to these people
alexander kaschlinski fernando atrio
barandella
daniel kozewski and harold ebeling in
order to register this phenomenon
the team of scientists collated the wmap
data and x-ray observations
and so it turned out that certain galaxy
clusters move at velocities reaching a
thousand kilometers per second
in the direction of a certain area of
space
aiming to cross the border of a
cosmological horizon
the flow stretches for up to 3 billion
light years
the process should be exclusively
accounted for by the presence of a large
object in that
area whose mass must be bigger than the
total mass of a really great number of
star clusters
it goes without saying that this value
must be extremely big
as the average mass of one cluster is a
staggering
10 to the power of 14 solar masses
if this really is the case here is the
first paradox we're faced with
in order to reach the border of the
observable universe and go beyond it
one has to move at superluminal speeds
which according to physical
laws is impossible
besides the big bang theory implies that
any cosmic structure
is supposed to be distributed evenly
that is why there is no way there is a
so
celestial giant out there beyond the
boundaries of the observable universe
if however this assumption proves to be
correct
then we are faced with a truly unique
anomaly whose nature should be explained
by a completely different
set of laws when attempting to account
for the phenomenon of the dark flow
scientists had to question certain
points in the big bang theory
supposing the newly born universe used
to be comprised of a multitude of
spheres
the matter at hand assumes a totally
different aspect
and then the existence of phenomena like
cell gargantuan objects
would be feasible some scientists
believe that at some point in the
distant past
our part of the universe could
hypothetically have been something like
a giant sphere
tucked away among a great number of
similar ones
then it exploded and rapidly began to
expand
the explosion in question could have
been the hypothetical big bang
and the growth of the sphere could be
what is now known as the expansion of
the universe
according to a few finer points of the
same theory
the former sphere that is our part of
the universe
has not lost all of its former
properties and continues to interact
with other universes
the latter's being of the same shape and
it is this interaction that causes star
clusters to move in what we now call the
dark flow
this description of the universe is of
course just another attempt to account
for this episode of its evolution
any concrete information about it is
effectively unavailable
nevertheless it is studying anomalies
that is able to reveal the most puzzling
nuances of this process
there is another hypothesis about the
nature of the dark flow
put forward by cosmologist and
theoretical physicist laura mercini
howton
the university of north carolina
according to her
the dark flow may be indicative of the
existence of a parallel universe
the towers used to be connected with on
a quantum mechanical level
billions upon billions of years ago
and then at some point it broke free as
a result of the big bang
this way the dark flow could have to do
with the rupture in the outer wall of
the universe's structure
this rupture would have been formed as a
result of our hypothetical detachment
from another universe
and as for the dark flow itself what we
see is matter flowing through the
rupture
unusual as it is even though this
hypothesis may not be supported by
all astrophysicists around the world at
least
the possibility of the existence of
something out there beyond our
understanding of the universe's laws
isn't dismissed as too fanciful or
incorrect
for example the prominent theoretical
physicist stephen hawking
went as far as to build a mathematical
model proving the hypothetical
possibility of there being a multiverse
containing a great number of universes
similar to our own
but in order to find out in which of the
proposed hypothesis its author is likely
to have hit the nail on the head
we have our work cut out for us first we
must define what all space around us
is made of
there are two basic principles regular
cosmological models are based on
the universe is isotropic that is it has
been developing in all directions
and must have a spherical shape if any
at all
and it is homogeneous that is it has no
directions or
shape isotropy means uniformity in all
orientations
while anisotropy means that properties
vary with the direction from which
they're measured
as for homogeneity it means uniformity
from point to point in space
it could be illustrated in the following
way wherever you were to find yourself
in the universe
the space around you would be more or
less the same
consequently the universe is isotropic
and homogeneous
however if on your journey through the
universe you were to bump into a great
body of matter moving in some direction
or other
this would mean that some parts of the
universe are anisotropic
thus the cosmological model would not
apply to those areas
the cosmological principles effectively
define the foundation for physical laws
for instance if the universe is
homogeneous
physical laws would apply in any part of
it wherever you were to gauge them
and large-scale structures like the dark
flow are actually not supposed to exist
in it
there is also the universally accepted
theory of a hierarchical universe
according to this theory originally all
large objects in space used to be tiny
but as time passed they emerged thus
growing to form
enormous galaxies however on discovering
the dark flow anomaly we realized that
these phenomena don't fit in the general
picture
the dark flow isn't supposed to exist in
the model of an isotropic universe
apart from that this phenomenon isn't
the only
example of a structure this large and
inexplicable
for example here are a few more
large-scale structures which are not
homogeneous
and which by far exceed the estimated
maximum size
which places the matards with the
general cosmological principles
the large quasar group spotted in 1991
measuring 580 megaparsecs
the sloan great wall discovered in 2003
measuring 423 megapass x
the hercules corona borealis great wall
measuring a staggering
10 billion light years
all these objects urge us to question
the generally accepted theories of the
origin
and evolution of our universe and by the
looks of it
the dark flow could prove to be the most
exciting of all
the mere assumption of its existence
prompted a number of new hypotheses
about what the observable universe
is made of if there is a motion of
galaxies taking place in it
and this movement is heading in a
particular direction and is not random
this means that the universe is able to
move in some direction or other it means
that assumptions that there are huge
irregular structures beyond the cosmic
horizon may hypothetically be correct
be it as it may today all these thoughts
and ideas are confined to theories
only and it is going to take a lot of
time to prove them true or false
but even if the dark flow becomes a
common truth it is a foregone conclusion
that it will only spawn a new
panoply of riddles in spite of the fact
that mankind has come a long way in
exploring and studying the world around
us
the phenomenon of the dark flow is yet
another confirmation that our knowledge
today
is only a tiny portion of the supreme
knowledge
and there is an infinitely longer way to
go yet
until only recently people used to
believe that the basic principles of the
universe are the irrefutable truth
today however with every new anomaly
discovered in outer space
this idea is becoming less and less
convincing
and for all we know the new generations
may well perceive the universe
in a completely different way
you